[chanting]
Richmond til we die!
We're Richmond til we die!
We know we are, we're sure we
are.
We're Richmond til we die!
Richmond til we die!
We know we are,
We're sure we are!
We're Richmond til we die!
Go Richmond!
[all cheering]
[music starts]
This is Roy Kent. This is Season
Three.
[clappers]
Let's go!
Let's go, come on!
[door opens]
Let's go, Coach.
Making this show has brought a
great deal of fulfillment, for
me personally.
And sometimes it'll bring tears
to my eyes.
We're going to do that again.
Sometimes it'll give me
goosebumps sometimes it'll just
make you warm.
-Did not see that coming.
-[laughing]
[laughing]
It's funny, thinking about the
things in your life that can
make you cry just knowing that they existed.
[Brett Goldstein]
We're the luckiest people in the
world.
If it were up to me we'd never
do anything else.
That's it, balance.
[laughing]
Let's go find a windmill!
We are coming right to the end,
aren't we?
Yes.
It's been a long road, this
season.
[applause]
My appreciation of the cast has
only deepened.
[applause]
It's funny because you develop
these friendships as real
people,
James Lance:
but then there's also your
friendships you have as the characters as well,
James Lance:
which is like a double whammy of
friendship.
That's good. That was good.
I didn't mean a word of that,
but I just thought it sounded
good.
David Elsendoorn:
They're all suckers, I hate
them.
[laughing]
Toheeb Jimoh:
They're like, yeah like family.
Like my brothers.
Richmond on three.
[laughing]
It's such a happy, silly gaggle.
And that is an almost entirely
unique circumstance to find
yourself in.
Oh I love you.
Being able to play out this
friendship on camera and off
camera,
That was, sensational.
Juno Temple:
has been a beautiful, magic
whirlwind.
[both laughing]
This show is bringing so much
happiness and joy to everyone.
[cheering]
It has been the most wonderful
experience. It's like a big
family.
It's just so good to be a part
of, even though I'm the villain.
[laughing]
I think we're all slightly nicer
people than we were at the
beginning of the job.
Nice.
God I hate what you've done to
me.
[somber music plays]
-Yeah.
-This is, this is it. This is
it.
This is the last day on Ted
Lasso Season 3.
I'm in full denial. Full.
[all talking]
I don't think anyone can really
believe it, process it.
Toheeb Jimoh:
I don't think I'm gonna cry.
-Nope.
-[laughter]
We'll come back to the end of
the day, and this man is
bawling.
-We'll come back at the end of
the day, and this man is
bawling. -He's crying.
We're at the end of it, and if
you can see behind me-
Last year we did NSYNC "Bye
Bye Bye," this year we're doing
"So Long, Farewell."
♪ There's a sad sort of clanging
from the clock in the hall, and
the bells in the steeple, too. ♪
[cheering]
The team organized a farewell
song for Ted,
Kola Bokinni:
to show how much
they appreciate him.
♪ Coo-coo, coo-coo. ♪
I believe when I asked to do it,
you see some of the boys like,
kinda, rejecting it a little bit.
[ball impacts]
Ow!
This is really distracting my
process.
And then by the end of it
everyone's like-
Five, six, seven, eight.
♪ So long, farewell. ♪
It's one of the final moments in
our third season.
And a very powerful and touching
moment.
♪ Adieu. ♪
[applause]
It gets to your heart, to your
funny bones, all bits of you.
♪ Goodbye. ♪
-That was nice.
-I think we nailed it!
Thank you, fellas. That was
perfect.
[cheering]
Rebecca:
I can afford to make you
one of the highest paid coaches in the league.
I know people say I'm crazy,
but-
I still think I'd be underpaying
you for what you mean to this
club.
Will you please stay?
If you're not ready to stop
being with someone, I don't
really know how to cope with it.
I've loved getting to know each
and every single one of you.
[laughing]
Ted:
Learning all about the men
you were,
and getting a front row
seat to see the men you're all
becoming.
I can't really talk about it
because I'll cry, so it's very
much still time for everyone.
It's a series of teary goodbyes.
We've all been on this journey
the exact same way as the fans.
I'm gonna cry.
[crying and laughing]
Goodbye, Ted. I owe you and this show
so much.
Nick Mohammed:
So thank you, Ted.
Genuinely makes me a bit-
See you later, Ted.
Adios, amigo.
Bye, Ted.
Stop talking, change the
subject.
Boss don't wanna talk about it
yet.
I'm right there with you.
Goodbye, Ted.
Love ya.
Been amazing.
Goodbye, Ted!
It was great knowing you.
Wanker.
Ted:
Getting to work with you all
these last three years,
has truly been one of the
greatest experiences of my life.
Ted:
I'm just so gosh damn proud
to be a part of this team.
Ted goes home, but we will be
together forever.
[laughing]
I love you Ted.
I love you too, Willis.
I've personally never been great
at goodbyes, so-
Jason Sudeikis:
I wish for everybody to live
with the experience of making this show and being a part of it
with the spirit in which it was
created.
I love you guys.
And I'm gonna miss you all.
Ted gave us the Lasso Way, and
we can go forth and preach it.
[music swells]
♪
A lot of folks like to say
there's no place like home.
And that's true,
But there ain't a whole lot of
places like AFC Richmond,
either.
[cheering]
I love you guys so very much.
On three.
One, two, three-
I love you guys so very much!
[cheering]